the paternotte
think of Holland I see
wide rivers
go slowly through endless lowlands and drive
unthinkable gray boxes
as
yes as bumps
stand at the end
and we want that box landscape
we want to tackle
because once those boxes are there
you will not get rid of it very quickly
the minister says sensible things about this
but I was wondering
he has 1 approach for those hyperscale data centers
where there are 2 places in the Netherlands
there they can come
but otherwise we will tackle that
and we also do that with national legislation
isn't that something you like with this one too
logistics centers
and I really mean that mega big xxl
where you also have to
you should also bring that into such a context
just like with the hyperstyle data centers
yeah there's actually something pretty similar
that we are doing now
namely that these rules actually also in this way
but then appear in the provincial ordinance
but the same in all provinces
because I have agreed that with the provinces
so that's actually 1 similar outcome
1 provincial ordinance has the same force
as 1 national instruction line
I also agreed with the provinces
I was not allowed to see that everywhere
the regulations are equally tightly adjusted
then I still come up with 1 national guideline
as we have done with the data centers
same goes for solar plan
there actually applies
the same for clear instructions
provinces that include this in their ordinance
and like that
should not turn out to be at any time
or in 1 province
then I can still
proceed to national instruction rules
and take for example brabant
Brabant suffers from this and the most
but also pulled his leg first
under the previous lecture period
I now have very clear rules about where
and where not
this type of logistics centers may take place
that Brabant example
is actually all over the country
followed at this time